[Música]
en uno de los colegios en los que
trabajo fue absolutamente evidente el
año pasado el gran necesario contar con
un baño inclusivo necesitamos tener un
baño en el que las personas más allá de
su identidad de género
independientemente de cómo se sintieran
ellos pueden el tranquilos a esos al
baño la discusión no fue sencilla
participamos de las mismas profesores
directivos alumnos padres propietarios
representantes legales y no soy un
tiempito ponernos de acuerdo encontramos
un lugar en el primer piso de la
secundaria un baño que era simplemente
es un baño un inodoro un lavabo
individual al que cualquiera podía
asistir y hacer sus necesidades
cómodamente pero como yo soy profe de
lengua aparte soy directivo en este
colegio para mí el signo es importante
entonces lo que iba estar en la puerta
de ese baño era importante entonces
empezamos a buscar con los chicos en
internet algunas imágenes que pudieran
servir está el tipito la señorita esta
cosa medio amorfa no nos parecía
significativa no nos parecía buena
entramos a buscar otras todas
coloridas muy diversas con diferentes
formas diferentes colores y empezó la
discusión porque algunas eran muy
complejas algunas eran muy sencillas no
estábamos de acuerdo por ejemplo esta
fue muy polémica si entendíamos que
quizá algunos colores eran
significativos y tienen que estar pero
no encontramos el acuerdo hicimos un
concurso de arte para poner la imagen en
la puerta del baño con alumnos de toda
la sección e hicimos un comité que
decidiera y en la reunión en la que el
comité estableciendo lo emocionados
aproximadamente unas 20 personas en 12
metros cuadrados docentes alumnos algún
padre se imagina en el fervor no había
acuerdo en que elegir y finalmente una
alumna en un pósito levantan la mano el
centro intentó la discusión
pongámosle baño y eso fue lo que hicimos
le pusimos un cartelito en la puerta que
dice simplemente baño porque es eso un
baño
las soluciones no siempre están en el
lugar en el que las buscamos eso
aprendimos ese día pero también aprendí
otras cosas que yo dije bueno me pueden
ser útiles para ministrar pse de lengua
la experiencia me hizo tomar conciencia
de que habíamos visibilizado un problema
lo habíamos puesto sobre el tapete que
habíamos tenido una actitud democrática
y eso estaba bueno porque todos habíamos
participado en la discusión y que
habíamos sido creativos en definitiva no
dije quizá pueda sacar de esta
experiencia algunos aspectos para
transformar mis clases de lengua en
espacios mucho más creativos mucho más
representativos los invito a que pasen a
una de mis clases de lenguaje
yo soy sergio tengo 51 años estoy casado
tengo tres hijos soy blanco de clase
media no tengo problemas para
presentarme la verdad es esa no distinto
sería si yo me sintiera de este modo
sería de otro foro u otro modo
completamente distinto y el primer
problema que tenemos es que tenemos que
ser visibles
que una de las competencias lingüísticas
elementales y básicas que tiene que
tener una persona es la de poder
presentarse a los demás de poder decir
quién es una competencia en lingüística
es la posibilidad de resolver con el
lenguaje algo determinado en una
situación concreta en una situación
determinada y es una competencia muy
pero muy básica que nosotros tenemos que
trabajar y tenemos que visibilizar y
hacer a los demás y nosotros mismos
tomar conciencia de que no siempre el
lenguaje esa herramienta tan poderosa
esa tecnología transformadora de la
realidad nos incluye a todos
pensé que por el estado bueno también
empezará a trabajar con la búsqueda de
palabras claves esa es otra competencia
como trabajamos los profes de lengua con
la comprensión textual bueno buscamos
palabras claves palabras que sean
significativas y dije bueno trabajemos
en el discurso social con las palabras
en las cuales nosotros transmitimos
información de género quizás sin darnos
cuenta y ahí vamos a encontrar como dijo
un alumno que un potro es un tipo
fornido si atractivo en cambio una yegua
es una mujer bastante intratable que un
toro es alguien fuerte vigoroso y que
ella pobrecita es tan adorable tan
divina la vaca cuando se usan referencia
una mujer no es ningún piropo en no es
ninguna cosa halagüeña podemos ver que
una zorra es una prostituta y un zorro
es alguien astuto pero a simple vista no
encontramos ninguna diferencia elemental
cuando llego a mis clases a veces llevo
música para trabajar estos temas y caigo
yo con mis canciones no siempre sé qué
es eso silvio rodríguez joan manuel
serrat serú girán soy profe de lengua y
están mis alumnos una mano el celular la
otra mano el parlante de bluetooth
lo beso de mi boca no fueron suficiente
para que te quedaras conmigo para
siempre basta
no me gusta la cumbia
claro propio usted porque no le gusta el
agua nosotros trabajamos con lo que le
gusta usted es nada más no me gusta la
cumbia la cumbia es todo lo mismo es
siempre la misma música no profe hay
cumbia que es diferente como es eso la
maldad tiene lo mismo que en este
ejemplo que no es lo mismo que los
palmeras que la cumbia tropical hay una
cumbia que es más machista que la otra
en serio sí profe si usted no diferencia
como dice usted invisibiliza
sinapsis
hay que estar atento hay que estar
alerta y hay que dejar que los demás
hablen y ser democráticos y eso trate de
hacer también en un colegio secundario
del conurbano profundo este año mientras
preparaba mis clases me di cuenta que
hay unos documentos que llaman nap son
núcleos de aprendizaje prioritarios los
docentes tenemos muchísimas islas en un
colegio y yo soy parte en otro colegio
soy mil nos encantan las islas stand up
quiere decir núcleos de aprendizaje es
prioritario es un documento donde dice
de cuarto a sexto año de la escuela
secundaria en literatura se pueden
trabajar todos estos contenidos y entre
esos todos contenidos estos contenidos
nosotros elegimos pero los profes de
lengua elegimos con lo que yo llamo
síndrome de estocolmo del canon qué
quiere decir esto que trabajamos siempre
con los mismos autores yo dije bueno
vamos a tratar de ser un poco más
creativos vamos a una lista de autores
para que los chicos elijan vamos a poner
fecha de nacimiento intereses qué sé yo
características estéticas que tienen los
autores bueno y así por supuesto puse en
la lista a jorge luís borges
puse a cortázar
es argentino es eje dentro de la
literatura argentina de hoy casares
sábato porque aparte era de la zona del
colegio que en santos lugares y roberto
dar porque me gusta un montón
dos minutos
profe
son todos hombres
si en verdad lo que enseñamos es en vez
de literatura argentina literatura
patriarcal porteña que es otra cosa
completamente diferente entonces bueno
vamos a poner a algunas mujeres ya que
me tomé la licencia de cortázar pongamos
la alfonsín ha sido una nación argentina
es parte de la literatura argentina y a
las hermanitas ocampo
profe
usted solamente lea gente muerta
bueno tienen razón pongamos la libertad
de micro culos el río de las congojas
lee brazos se los recomiendo pongamos
también porque no angélica gorodischer
como triunfar en la vida del libro de
cuentos salgan de aquí vayan a comprarlo
y orozco olguita ya murió pero a mí me
encanta es una poeta increíble y una más
joven para que no digan que todas son
más de 80 años porque esa es la pregunta
que venía y pusimos a selva almada
obviamente selva fue la primera de la
lista si el desapego es una forma de
querernos es un título con mucho gancho
que trajo digamos como mucha intriga en
los chicos en las chicas y es parte este
año de mis clases de lengua en esa
escuela del conurbano profundo no les
digo que mis clases hacen que los
alumnos lean como locos pero la verdad
es que mejoró bastante porque fuimos un
poco más democráticos abrimos el juego y
lo hicimos de otra manera también
digamos que otra de las cosas que ayudan
en la educación con el lenguaje es con
la posibilidad de ser más creativos de
incorporar la lengua popular de
incorporar aquellos elementos que son
parte de nuestra vida cotidiana y traer
discursos no tan convencionales al aula
por ejemplo se me ocurrió que podíamos
trabajar con piropos podríamos comenzar
hablando del origen etimológico de la
palabra que viene del trigo piro fuego y
ops mirada con fuego en la mirada que no
estaría mal y preguntarle una alumna que
siente cuando va caminando por la calle
y escucha que le dicen
me gustaría ser baldosa para mirarte la
cosa
o cuando alguien dice con tinta negra te
escribo porque en negra es mi suerte en
esta noche oscura te extraño y no puedo
tenerte donde las repente lo negro lo
oscuro es algo negativo porque el
problema de la discriminación el
problema de la nueva inclusión en el
lenguaje va más allá de la cuestión de
género hasta nuestro el color de piel
nuestras creencias más profundas
nuestros deseos se ven muchas veces
dejado de lado en el lenguaje marcado
como algo negativo en el lenguaje y
donde esto se ve con muchísima violencia
es en las redes sociales hoy por hoy es
imposible pensar en clases de lengua
donde no se trabaje con las redes
sociales porque nuestros alumnos
conviven todo el tiempo con youtube con
instagram con snap chat trabajan con
twitter con tweets con mixer streamers
youtubers gamers y nuestros alumnos uno
se dice algo para dicen
y ese nada quiere decir que saben
perfectamente que de nazi es sinónimo de
que algo es alocado o divertido por
contar con la costura me lo impusieron
de esa manera
hubiéramos pensado por ahí que el
término de nazi podría estar asociado a
lo bueno a lo divertido
pensaba yo cuando preparaba esta charla
en una anécdota que me mostrará como
alumno como profe y eso fue hace mucho
tiempo pero encontré una cuando la
escuela a la que yo iba
cumplirá 75 años como yo estaba en el
centro de estudiantes la dirección se
vio forzada a invitarme a decir unas
palabras en ese acto dije un discurso
muy chiquitito
en el que si exprese que soñaba con qué
la escuela algún día nos dejará de
considerar a nosotros los alumnos como
simples números en una libreta y que
viera el potencial que todos teníamos
2 mil 500 compañeros estallaron en
innovación yo me puse ancho y como no
termina un discurso va a ir todo el
mundo lo saluda no y estaba la directora
no le saluda me da la mano así y me dice
al oído
garcía tiene 10 amonestaciones
tuve una enseñanza y aprendía algo que
el lenguaje es una tecnología increíble
poderosa transformadora de la realidad y
lo digo en esta casa de estudios no hay
tecnología más fuerte que el lenguaje y
poder tener aulas que sean inclusivas es
un modo de hablar verdaderamente del
lenguaje inclusivo
yo sé yo sé que quizá ustedes esperaban
que hablara de la letra e que hablara de
palabras como chicas como amigas
la verdad es que no esa charla sobre el
cambio lingüístico y mucho más técnica
no no no digo no es importante si es muy
importante pero imaginen si yo me ponía
hablarles a ustedes los impares y los
falsos del latín del participio presente
activo de la caída del género neutro en
el idioma castellano de cómo se produce
un cambio lingüístico según la razón de
prestigio
de que siempre en un principio en el
lenguaje que tiene que ver con la
economía
no creo que haya sido tan positivo creo
sí que a partir de estas tres
estrategias a partir de visibilizar a
partir de ser democráticos a partir de
ser creativos podemos encontrar un
camino para crear un lenguaje mucho más
inclusivo desde la escuela esa escuela
en la que hoy 35 años después y como
director sigo soñando esa escuela en la
que se nos reconozca como individuos que
somos indistintamente distintos
[Aplausos]
[Música]